hey ich bin thomas ich bin auf youtube
und instagram als tory aktiv und
arbeitet als selbständiger visual
effects artist katar und kameramann an
musikvideos videos youtuber
fernsehproduktion und natürlich an
meinen eigenen youtube kanal
ich war wieder auf einer filmschule noch
habe ich eine ausbildung gemacht denn
ich habe mir alles über neun jahre
hinweg selbst beigebracht und deswegen
bin ich mir sicher dass du das auch
schafft nur viel schneller und damit es
dir nicht so geht wie mir und du dich
jahrelang durch mittelmäßige tutorials
durch - von denen dann auch noch die
allerwenigsten auf deutsch sind habe ich
beschlossen selbst kurse zu machen mit
denen du schnellstmöglich die welt der
digitalen kunst meisten kannst in diesem
kurs geht es um das schneiden mit mir
probe kurs ist wie hier sehr sehr gut
strukturiert und beinhaltet sachen wie
filmmaterial importieren keyframes
arbeiten mit bildern und text wie man
verschiedene effekte anwenden zum
beispiel zuschneiden weichzeichnen wie
man es wenn man zwar stabilisiert und
wie man mit einem greenscreen arbeitet
und hier unten zum schluss eben
verarbeitung und deswegen kann ich mit
ganzem herzen sagen dass ich da wirklich
einen wissen in möglichst kurzer
zeitspanne gesteckt habe damit möglichst
schnell möglichst viel lernen kannst
also wenn du interesse hast dann freue
ich mich dass alles mit ihr zu teilen
[Musik]